ich werde nicht im detail darauf
eingehen wie sich die internationale
situation derzeit entwickelt die welt
fiebert immer mehr weiterhin nach beginn
der russisch militärischen
sonderoperation hat der kollektive
westen unter der führung der usa
weiterhin massiv druck ausgeübt auf
russland und es geht hier natürlich
nicht um die ukraine selbst die
amerikaner und ihre satelliten haben das
land schon lange zu einer schachfigur
verwandelt im mehrjährigen spiel gegen
russland jetzt wird das schicksal der
internationale weltordnung entschieden
ob diese wirklich gerecht demokratisch
und polizist sein wird oder ob
ein enger kreis der staaten unter der
führung von washington eine unipolare
wirtschaftsordnung und weltordnung eine
neokoloniale trennung der welt auf
exklusive und derjenige die deren willen
erfüllen werden drinnen wird wir sehen
dass diejenigen die gegen diese figuren
sind darunter sind auch russland und
belarus es gibt versuche sie einzudämmen
mit schmierigen unreinen die politischen
instrumenten sie mischen sich ein in
politische angelegenheiten es geht auch
um desinformationen es freut uns dass
unsere belarussischen freunde wie viel
das andere länder der welt auch das ganz
klar verstehen wir schätzen das
verständnis und die unterstützung durch
minsk sehr für die militärische
sonderoperation in der ukraine
die kollegen aus belarus
haben unsere arbeit sehr hoch und
positiv eingeschätzt hinsichtlich der
klinischen krise ist es sehr wichtig
wahrheitsgemäße informationen zu
bekommen in anbetracht der unverfrorenen
lügen in den westlichen medien ich bin
mir sicher dass eine richtige antwort
eine weitere erweiterung der
zusammenarbeit mit unseren nächsten
alliierten sein wird und unseren
gleichgesinnten darunter auch im rahmen
der organisation des vertrages über
kollektive sicherheit ovks organisation
und in der geo es heute gibt es in einer
ganzen reihe von staaten in europa
zuerst im baltischen raum in der ukraine
treiben neonazistischen und andere
radikale ihr unwesen
propaganda wird verstärkt von
fremdenfeindlichkeit russe phobie und
man braucht systemische umfassende
bemühungen um das zu neutralisieren und
diese gefährlichen trends zu bekämpfen
und ich bin mit sicher dass
diese unsere kommission auch ihren
beitrag dazu leisten wird